messieurs bonsoir journal un peu plus
court qu'à l'habitude en raison du droit
de réponse dont va bénéficier
l'opposition à la suite de la
communication de robert boulin
avant-hier soir donc à 20h15 c'est à
dire après le journal les points de vue
de françois mitterrand pour le ps et
charles fiterman pour le pc et puis
lundi à 20h30 un débat entre le ministre
et les quatre principales formations
représentées par un groupe à l'assemblée
nationale tout de suite donc l'événement
le plus important de la journée
la proclamation de la loi martiale en
iran au lendemain du succès d'énormes
manifestations de rues dans tout le pays
la loi martiale c'est-à-dire un
couvre-feu durant toute la nuit
l'armée peut tirer à vue sur quiconque
et l'interdiction de toute réunion les
milliers de jeunes gens alors mené une
véritable bataille de rue aujourd'hui
contre les soldats bilan des
affrontements bilan approximatif environ
200 morts je crois que l'on peut
véritablement parler de tournant dans
l'évolution des choses
une évolution qui se précisait depuis
quelques semaines déjà
l'assaut des militaires a duré plusieurs
heures tout a commencé place jallet
rebaptisée par les manifestants place
des martyrs ce matin environ 5000
manifestants bravent la loi martiale et
se dirige vers le sud est de la ville là
c'est le premier contact avec l'armée
qui a pris place aux points stratégiques
les militaires tentent de repousser les
manifestants dont quelques femmes
il refuse de se retirer et s'assoit sur
la chaussée c'est alors que la première
rafale par les manifestants se ruent
alors vers les quartiers pauvres du sud
et commence à dresser des barricades qui
seront réduites à coups de canon
les affrontements de téhéran aurait fait
plus de 200 morts annoncés agence
plusieurs milliers disent les opposants
au régime dont plusieurs des leurs ont
été arrêtés les rues qu habituellement
grouille de monde se sont vidés la
réaction terrible des militaires marc un
terme à l' avantage qui avait pris
l'opposition depuis lundi dernier
l'ayatollah charritte madori principal
chef religieux d'iran modéré refuse la
violence
pas d'armes ni de guérilla pour ses
fidèles nous ne les encourageons pas à
prendre les armes
ce que nous demandons est légal
nous disons aussi que le gouvernement
que mais des actions hors la loi qu'il
ne doit pas fait l'utilisation des armes
ne serait pas bénéfique pour notre cause
pour la cause que nous défendons 6 de
notre part nous utilisons les armes
ce sera contraire aux intérêts des
musulmans et de la population
cela n'apporterait rien à notre cause
aucune crèche et bientôt vous revenez
tout juste dix rangs il ya encore lui
qui à teyran alors vous avez plus
enquêter quelle est la nature exacte de
cette opposition mis en opposition et
canalisées par les religieux on les
appelle communément les religieux et que
je vous dise que ces religieux regroupe
des commerçants les petits commerçants
des artisans est véritablement des gens
du peuple qui ont trouvé à travers la
religion des endroits de réunion ne peut
pas se réunir à téhéran très facilement
alors l'endroit où l'on parle religion
et où on parle surtout politique
c'est la mosquée et d'enfiler votre
religion beaucoup d'importance dans les
mosquées les ayatollahs le responsable
religieux harangue les fidèles
commentent les décisions politiques
comme manque la nomination d'un premier
ministre et tout se passe à l'intérieur
des mosquées
c'est pourquoi vous avez remarqué
souvent que les les manifestations se
situe à la sortie des mosquées
alors et ils sont très nombreux ou
penser à réclamer le départ du shah
chose impensable il ya un mois encore et
bien il y à beaucoup de monde qui
réclame le départ du shah mais je crois
que le problème du chat n'est pas
véritablement important j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec plusieurs
représentants religieux etc religieux
l'appelle parfois sa majesté donc avec
un certain respect le problème du char
n'est pas essentiel ce que l'on souhaite
les religieux c'est que le chat est
disons un rôle de représentativité de
l'iran qu'il est un petit peu le rôle de
la reine d'angleterre en angleterre mais
ce que les religieux avec tous les gens
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
veulent détruire échanger c'est le
gouvernement les religieux veulent en
revenir à cette constitution de 1906 qui
réclament la présence de religieux à
l'intérieur même du parlement
il faut dans ce parlement cinq religieux
des ayatollahs sans doute qu'ils ont un
droit de veto sur les lois qui serait
promulguée
il vous semble que le chat est encore
brut partisans le chat a
vraisemblablement des partisans ils ne
se sont pas beaucoup médiation pour
manifester ce que j'ai vu en rentrant
c'est qu'il y avait des files d'attentes
importante à l'aéroport de téhéran et
que beaucoup d'iraniens voulez regarder
ce qui se passe en iran mais de
l'extérieur titre numéro deux de la
journée le dénouement chez terrain ça se
termine mal l'afer est mise en
liquidation et les syndics ont annoncé
le licenciement collectif de tout le
personnel c'est à dire dans l'immédiat
250 salariés mais le groupe terrain qui
se font aujourd'hui c'est aussi douze
autres sociétés sans compter plusieurs
centaines d'entreprises sous traitantes
gilbert fournis est le patron des
chantiers du havre avait posé comme
conditions au rachat des ateliers
terrain le licenciement de 600 personnes
ce plan a été repoussée à une large
majorité par l'assemblée générale du
personnel
dès lors on ne pouvait envisager d'issue
pour les syndicats c'est à la fois bien
entendu un drame social et une
catastrophe économique pour la région
en repoussant le plan fournier ils ont
voulu marquer leur refus de cette
alternative selon eux cette unique
alternative licenciement partiel ou
liquidation
la parole était globalement ou le
rapport produit on a rejeté les
conséquences se dira pas fournir sur
l'emploi et sur le statut dans les
passes à laval nous sommes entièrement
d'accord pour toute solution
industrielle qu'elle soit qu'elles
viennent de monsieur fournier ou
d'autres entrants qui lui garantissent
un spécial l'activité de la réparation
navale
l'emploi est notre statut
ces trente deux ans que je travaille dit
ici et bien sûr j'ai 48 ans je sais pas
ce qu'on fera de moi ailleurs puisque
dix ans j'ai été forgée dans cette
maison j'ai été élevé dans cette maison
et la reconversion c'est beau mais en
quoi comment nous avons une spécialité
bien déterminée ici pour faire quoi plus
tard six mois l'avenir
je ne sais pas ce que je vais devenir ça
ça dépendra tout de la transformation de
la maison éventuel un nouveau président
pour les jeunes agriculteurs michel fau
succès de je ne sais faire à l'issue du
16e congrès du cnj et puis après georges
séguy après nos mères c'était au tour
d'andré bergeron de faire son discours
de rentrée devant 12000 militants la
région parisienne il a répété que pour
lui si la politique conventionnelle
était bien une fin en soi et il a
demandé à nouveau la cinquième semaine
de congés payés et d'abord la réduction
de la durée du temps de travail
il faut par tous continuer à revendiquer
résolument la cinquième semaine de
congés payés
plus du tiers des salariés français au
la cinquième semaine
il est juste d'exiger la même chose pour
les autres et qu'on ne vienne pas nous
dire que les travailleurs sont moins que
nous attacher à cette revendication
un récent sondage a démontré le
contraire
alors battons-nous pour la cinquième
semaine afin que l'emprunt
non prochain
au rassemblement de rentrée nous ayons
remporté la victoire
la page robert fabre est tournée a dit
michel crépeau son successeur la tête
des radicaux de gauche mais le
député-maire de la rochelle n'a pas
caché que certains membres de son parti
suivrait robert fabre et quitterait le
émergé il ya d'ailleurs quelques remous
dans les fédérations de province quant
au ps il estime que robert femme ne peut
plus être apparenté au groupe socialiste
de l'assemblée nationale le parti
communiste en deuil les obsèques de jean
canapa ont eu lieu cet après midi au
cimetière du père lachaise à paris et
c'est georges marchais qui a prononcé
son éloge funèbre jean canapa telle vie
partage avec son parti des illusions et
des erreurs qu'il ne cherchait pas à
oublier ou à minimiser jour après jour
avec le parti il en tirer la leçon
un nouveau patron pour la rédaction
l'express sur françois revel remplacera
le triumvirat qui dirigeait jusqu alors
la rédaction de l'hebdomadaire la suite
de l'actualité toujours en bref met en
image chez toi monsieur ceyrac le
président du patronat français a été
reçu aujourd'hui par monsieur boulin le
ministre du travail qui entame est ainsi
une série de rencontres avec les
partenaires sociaux
monsieur chirac a indiqué que le cnpf
négociait actuellement avec les
syndicats
l'indemnisation du chômage et
l'aménagement du temps de travail avec
monsieur boulin un tour d'horizon a été
fait sur l'ensemble des problèmes de
l'emploi
le président houphouët boigny à déjeuner
à l'elysée avec le président giscard
d'estaing problèmes évoqués celui du
sahara occidental pour le président
ivoirien il existe une volonté de paix
la côte d'ivoire a des contacts avec la
mauritanie le maroc et le polisario sans
pour autant être officiellement
médiateur celui de l'afrique du sud
seul le dialogue permettra une meilleure
compréhension
à l'étranger poursuite du dialogue à
quand des vies poursuite au ralenti en
raison des fêtes religieuses des uns les
autres
le vendredi pour anouar el-sadate eux
samedi pour menahem begin le dimanche
pour le bassiste jimmy carter luigi
ringot le ministre des affaires
étrangères a quitté hanoi ce matin après
une visite officielle de deux jours au
vietnam qui a permis de relancer une
coopération qui battait un peu de l'ale
ces derniers temps les conversations ne
sont hachées qu'un peu plus tard puisque
le ministre a rencontré samedi le
premier ministre vietnamien quelques
heures après c'est aussi à bangkok mort
du batteur du groupe pop les ou faith
moon est mort d'une overdose c'est à
dire d'une attention massive de drogues
les trois autres membres de ce groupe
britannique sont en réunion ou décider
de l'avenir bbu leus ce groupe dont on
entendait tommy et puis la confirmation
d'une libération celle de guy desnoyers
un nom qui vous dira davantage quand
j'aurai précisé qu'il s'agit de l'ancien
curé d'uruffe condamné il y a vingt ans
pour le meurtre de l'une de ces jeunes
paroissienne qui attendait un enfant de
lui dit desnoyers était le plus ancien
prisonnier de france
il a en fait été libéré le 5 août et on
apprend la nouvelle qu'aujourd'hui il
serait à l'heure actuelle dans un
monastère
enfin vous raconter en compagnie d'henri
galets l'histoire du partage avec son
parti des illusions et des erreurs qu'il
ne cherchait pas à oublier ou à
minimiser jour après jour avec le parti
il en tire est là sont un nouveau patron
pour la rédaction de l'express sur
françois revel remplacera le triumvirat
qui dirigeait jusqu alors la rédaction
de l'hebdomadaire la suite de
l'actualité toujours en bref met en
image chez toi monsieur chirac le
président du patronat français a été
reçu aujourd'hui par monsieur boulin le
ministre du travail qui entame est ainsi
une série de rencontres avec les
partenaires sociaux
monsieur chirac a indiqué que le cnpf
négociait actuellement avec les
syndicats l'indemnisation du chômage et
l'aménagement du temps de travail avec
monsieur boulin un tour d'horizon a été
fait sur l'ensemble des problèmes de
l'an
le président houphouët boigny à déjeuner
à l'elysée avec le président giscard
d'estaing problèmes évoqués celui du
sahara occidental pour le président
ivoirien il existe une volonté de paix
la côte d'ivoire a des contacts avec la
mauritanie le maroc et le polisario sans
pour autant être officiellement
médiateur celui de l'afrique du sud
seul le dialogue permettra une meilleure
compréhension à l'étranger poursuite du
dialogue à quand des vies poursuite au
ralenti en raison des fêtes religieuses
des uns et les autres le vendredi pour
anouar el sadate samedi pour menahem
begin le dimanche pour le baptiste jimmy
carter luigi ringot le ministre des
affaires étrangères a quitté hanoi ce
matin après une visite officielle de
deux jours au vietnam qui a permis de
relancer une coopération qui battait un
peu de l'ale ces derniers temps les
conversations ne sont hachées qu'un peu
plus tard puisque le ministre a
rencontré pham van dong le premier
ministre vietnamien quelques heures
après cette fois ci à bangkok mort du
batteur du groupe pop nebbou cayce moon
est mort d'une overdose c'est à dire
d'une attention massif de drogue
les trois autres membres de ce groupe
britannique sont en réunion ou à décider
de l'avenir des goûts les housses groupe
dont on entendait tommy et puis la
confirmation d'une libération celle de
guy desnoyers un nom qui vous dira
davantage quand j'aurai précisé qu'il
s'agit de l'ancien curé d'uruffe
condamné il y a vingt ans pour le
meurtre de l'une de ces jeunes
paroissienne qui attendait un enfant de
lui dit desnoyers était le plus ancien
prisonnier de france
il a en fait été libéré le 5 août et on
apprend la nouvelle qu'aujourd'hui il
serait à l'heure actuelle dans un
monastère flores va vous raconter en
compagnie d'henri galets l'histoire du
boulanger de buffières buffière un petit
village de 300 habitants petit village
pauvre dans le charolais buffière qui un
beau matin s'étaient retrouvées sans
boulanger les deux qu'elle avait jusqu
alors partant à la retraite
alors mes chers amis son orgueil dans sa
poche et a lancé un appel à la radio
je vous rappelle les quelques uns des
messages que nous avons reçu ce matin un
village de son et loire mulliez un
village de 300 habitants se trouve sans
boulanger depuis plus d'un mois alors si
vous souhaitez vous installer en
province
si vous êtes intéressé par cette annonce
vous appelez tout simplement la mairie
de bussière aux 16 85
il y a quelques jours c'est une brève
annonce à france inter a déclenché un
petit raz de marée la mairie de
buffières reçu près de 90 appelle la
plupart venant de la ville de boulanger
désireux de travailler à la campagne et
buffers a retrouvé un boulanger un jeune
ouvrier portugais dans une boulangerie
de la région parisienne c'est décider
maintenant
vasco et son épouse marguerite
s'installent à la campagne voilà je
parle franchement c'est que j'allais
déjà relevé de paris ça fait pas
longtemps aussi à face ils ont su en
france j'en ai ras-le-bol de parler et
un deuxième c'est que moi j'étais dans
la campagne et ça m'a fait plaisir de
revenir à la campagne
madame monsieur boutant lui après 48 ans
passés dans le fournil va pouvoir
entamer une retraite paisible avec la
satisfaction d'avoir trouvé un
remplaçant personnes de venir à la
campagne le travail est dur à la copains
parce qu'il ya le portage en plus du
travail fourni et qu'il avait bien sûr
les habitants de la commune n'aurait pas
manquer de pain à une boulangerie
industrielle était prête à livrer le
village mais ici on regarde le bain de
la ville en plaignant très très fort les
citadins qui sont obligés de le manger
et qui à côté de la boulangerie il ya le
bistrot ce qui permet de joindre l'utile
à l'agréable de faire les coachs et de
traquer les amis
à buffières le conseil municipal et les
290 habitants du village en était
conscient la fermeture de la boulangerie
c'était un pas dans la tombe pour cette
petite commune rurale il y a un siècle
en effet le village comptait encore près
de 900 habitants
et puis à l'image d'autres beaux
français peu à peu buffière a vu ces
jeunes partir aujourd'hui on compte ici
67 retraités et plus du tiers des
maisons du village sont devenus
résidence secondaire oui beaucoup
n'aiment pas ce qu'on n'aurait qui
veulent s'installer où d'importants
développements entre deux recensements
de 1968 à 1975 dans ce département de
saône et loire les communes rurales ont
perdu 40 % de leur population est
appelée communes rurales une commune de
moins de 5000 habitants
si à l'échelon national on n'a pas
enregistré de diminution des populations
entre 68 et 75 cela s'explique les
jeunes agriculteurs continuent à s'en
aller mais souvent ils sont remplacés
par des retraités venus de la ville ce
qui accentue encore le vieillissement
des populations dans ces villages
beaucoup de parents désolé jeunes et
sortir le remuant ville-campagne papé
qui continue à mieux de la terre ça sert
à rien ça n'apporte rien ces progrès
l'exode rural c'est aussi il faut bien
le dire le fatalisme paysans pourtant ce
qui s'est passé à buffières peut servir
d'exemple
il a suffi d'un appel à la radio
buffière roi sont peints cet hiver
buffière conservera aussi ce que non pas
ceux de la ville le paysage l'air pur et
le temps de prendre le temps
voilà terminons ce bref journal avec
l'histoire de deux familles heureuses
d'abord cette marseillaise de 62 ans qui
viennent gagné près de 8 millions de
francs au loto elle avait joué les dates
de naissance de ses enfants
et puis dans un tout autre ordre d'idées
la performance de madame l'eau ce qui a
donné naissance hier soir à toulouse à
des quintuplés trois filles et deux
garçons le couple avait déjà un garçon
de 5 ans la page de la météo aujourd'hui
beaucoup de nuages sur le pays et un
temps assez médiocre malgré quelques
éclaircies
demain se ranger un peu belles
éclaircies sur les régions
méditerranéennes mais beaucoup de nuages
sur la manche
agger après une matinée brumeuse des
éclaircies se développeront les
températures varieront voilà avant le
ciné-club vers 22h40 bernard pradines au
vous présentera le dernier journal je
vous remercie de nous avoir écoutés je
vous souhaite une excellente semaine
bonne soirée à tous à lundi